coming up next the men lose at more
financially but in the long run the
court they got lucky they can go and get
any younger that they want money is
associated with as well so do you think
a guy is a good candidate for a
relationship if he's constantly having
failed situationships with women so
people are gonna eventually forget that
he's been divorced if he moves on with
another person couldn't you figure that
out before a relationship by asking
certain questions so Tom Brady and
Gisele I'm sorry guys I can never say
her last name Boon Shen I'm officially
divorced on October 28 2022. legal teams
from both say that and not an ironclad
prenup agreement was put in place before
they were married in 2009 making the
financial aspects of the divorce
relatively smooth what has happened
since is there what has happened since
then and why are they both in the new
sense Gisele has been linked with her
children's Jujitsu instructor Joe main
Valentine a 42 year old Brazilian man
with some specular relating that they
have had something going on before the
official divorce he started appearing on
giselle's social media around February
showing Giselle basic techniques on
Instagram he has also been seen
traveling with Giselle and the children
since the beginning of the year Tom
Brady 45 officially confirmed that he is
dating Veronica rajak a 26 year old
Slovakian model with over 3.2 million
Instagram followers she has attended a
few of a few of his games and has taken
photographs wearing his jersey Gerard
Peak and Shakira were in a relationship
from 2011 to 2022 having two children
during that time after breaking up in
Gerard Peak 36 years old has been
confirmed to be in a relationship with
23 year old Clara Chia Marty Shakira has
moved from Spain to her family's home in
Miami Florida and has been linked to her
24 year old surfing instructor custody
of the children is still pending this
begs the question who normally wins
after high profile breakups men or women
um
I'll start here and then go around a man
or woman actually I think I managed to
hear what other people got to say first
I can't lie Okay who wants anyone
opinionated want to start come come on
just depends on how that what the
situation is so if there's obviously
kids involved um
oh
um
I say mendu okay yeah because
it's like no matter what their the
publicity just sort of like dies down on
them whereas women they get it a lot
more
that makes sense
I don't know
so I can't explain it so like some men
have more publicity after they say no
they get publicity
um
but it's not as much as like it wouldn't
go as long as what the woman's publicity
would go on for if that makes sense so
like there would be more Paparazzi
watching the wimp the woman
um her every move who she's dealt with
and then sort of like you'd hear once in
a blue moon if the man decides to leave
and show off that he's got a new woman
then they would catch him but it's like
a one-off one-off story and then that's
it bye okay that's what I see so you
would dictate who wins and loses after
the breakup by who has less publicity
yeah because it good all publicities can
be good but comes with bad as well a lot
of negative okay
I think after a high profile breakup
right the women
the the Outlook from the society that
they get is kind of crazy I think they
get told
that they're not good for fine moving on
and finding someone else so
and also it's mostly men
in high profile breakups that money is
associated with as well so as soon as
the female goes and finds another
partner as always she like she doesn't
bother in the relationship did you get
it and that's what I think and it's kind
of that's true if one a woman's moving
from relationship to relationship to
relationship then maybe she isn't the
best fit or the best candidate for a
relationship
I think a woman that moves from a
literature to relationship knows what
she wants in a relationship because I'm
going to tell you not a lot of people
out there like are gonna be what you
want them to be so move I would say
personally move around as much as you
want until you find the right one but
couldn't you figure that out before a
relationship like by asking certain
questions
um some things you have to live to
actually know because some people they
know stuff but in order how they apply
it practically is completely different
you can know so much but once you get
into a relationship it's way more
sacrifices way more compromisation that
gets involved that I think
is important and if you need to move
around as much as much relationships as
you need to to get that security to
finally understand that these situations
won't work for you then that's what you
might need to do and I think the more
women do get looked weirdly for that but
it's what you've got to do at the end of
the day men do it too so do you think a
guy is a good candidate for a
relationship if he's constantly having
failed situationships with women like if
he if he's maybe in a two-year span
dated like 20 girls do you think it's
likely he's going to date you
sorry I mean if I know Ahmad has dated
20 women I wanted to come date me I'd
kind of be like and but then it kind of
contradicts what I just said yeah but at
the same time as a man if a woman has
gone through 30 men and came up to me
and said I wanna have a relationship
with you I'd kind of be like what's up
you know and also as much as I said
compromisation is required there are
stuff you have to learn and go through
sometimes you have to stick in a
relationship for you to actually make
stuff work it doesn't necessarily be
moving on to other ones but just because
you moved on from relationship
relationship to relationship it doesn't
mean you're crazy
so
okay go ahead
um either of you you go ahead okay sorry
um so was this question reserved
specifically for high profile
relationships or uh just relationships
can you tell me your opinion on both
high profile and regular yeah sure so
high profile I think is a little bit
worse because say with them also can't
pronounce the name Gisele Bundchen I
think that's how you say it
um Tom Brady it's he's probably going to
be one of the most wealthy top 10 type
of men that she'll ever be with and
because women we're hyper and
hypergamous by Nature we typically can't
date down and she would struggle to find
someone especially at her age now that
she has children unfortunately and that
would give her what she wants which will
probably be marriage
um so I think that applies to most high
profile relationships because they have
some form of Celebrity Status therefore
their Partners will probably be a notch
ahead of them uh
whereas for normal people like us
um I think women generally unfortunately
still do losing a break in a breakup
um in the short term they're winning
because they can find a simp to buy them
a bag and take them places and they can
find men to fit different roles of a
partner but in the long term they would
lose because they'll struggle to
actually find someone who wants to be
with them and vice versa and they'll
probably get to say 35 No Children
because they've been playing the field
whereas if they stayed in the
relationship providing it's not abusive
you know the exceptions to the rule and
they try to make it work it probably
could have been happier
um in the long term
I don't necessarily think that a breakup
means that you're going to start
sleeping around start dating around I
think some women do wait I find men do
move on pretty quick and they seem to
not be as picky
I do think that they move on a bit
quicker
um I don't know I
I'm unsure of my opinion because there's
so many different variables like
do they have kids do they are they
married were they together for a long
time I'm just saying if there's a
hundred high-profile breakups who tips
high profile who typically wins men or
women can it be none of them because
there's so much drama around it
oh okay
um
I think the woman the woman yeah tell me
why because as I said the man moves on
very quick and he's not as picky and he
can seem to get a lot younger partner
than than a woman would if a woman's had
children then there's that to uh um the
women lose
what did the women lose yeah it seems
like you're saying the man so yeah like
a younger what I'm saying is that they
can't move on maybe they want a
relationship after that breakup and it's
harder for them because they have
children maybe
um and then there's more to consider
it's not just black and white even
though the man has children as well when
they move on that's that doesn't seem to
hinder their day and experience they can
still date and move on and do what they
want it doesn't stop that
so it's just based on what you said it
sounds like you're saying that the women
lose and the men win yeah okay okay you
said the opposite when you started I
thought I said no I thought I said that
the women lose
I thought am I crazy maybe maybe yeah
some maybe you did okay um go ahead
I think it's it is a difficult one it is
a broad one
um I think in if you're looking at high
profile celebrity status and breakups
um
I think generally depending on how they
break up I think it depicts on how it
would end up but probably women would
lose in terms of emotionally I think
especially if there's children as well
um pretty much
in times of
men I don't think they're emotionally
attached as much as women I think women
tend to be more emotionally attached
than men so
in a breakup I think when women break up
they break up way before they actually
physically break up with a man whereas a
man
I think they're quite flippant and they
will do it spare at the moment it's how
they're feeling so I think in terms of
who generally wins I would probably say
men in that aspect because I feel like
they're mentally their way before women
are probably there
okay what do you think
um
see I think the opposite to you I feel
like a woman knows in her head that
she's gonna break up with a guy
before
she's actually gonna do it yeah like the
other way around
I think yeah you just repeated exactly
what she said my bad
um so yeah I feel like
when it comes to actually breaking up
I feel like women are more prepared for
that actually happening
then I don't think men think to
especially if they're comfortable in the
relationship
they're not really
thinking about it too tough so I would
say maybe men lose more because
I just think they're gonna they don't
see it coming as often do you think men
are more hurt after breakups than women
like women move on quicker Yeah okay or
like
they start that process before yeah
because by the time the woman does it
she's been thinking about it for six
months what do you think about dating
options after do you think who do you
think typically is more dating options
after a relationship men or women
I think it depends on the man or the
woman right so in high profile cases
um
again I think it depends on the if you
had to pick one
maybe men in high profile okay cases
because say for a high profile man
you'll have more women wanting to
do Elfie then the other way around
Auntie what do you think
at first I was in sight
before you brought the sixes into it I
was gonna say the person with
the most money
wins initially because they're out of it
but then the women
but that's it's the man and he's got
most money and they split up then the
woman might think she's winning because
she gets like money and the kids and
whatever
but then she's
less attractive
to the outside world so she might
thought she's a win she might think
she's one initially
but then I think the men in the end win
because they can get any woman out there
they want younger that looks a whole lot
better than the old bag that they've
left so you know all the stretch marks
and everything's gone because when you
look at all of those whoever had the
most money
got someone younger
and even though their partner's gone and
football yeah like um
what do you call the the guy the perfume
the aftershave Guy what's his name
the one you just mentioned Tom Brady
yeah that's him
I don't know then I have to shave names
like that or something
you're thinking oh sorry yeah
okay I know it's something to do with
sports but
he split up
and she's gonna she's got this guy so
when they said about women I find that
in the public eye sometimes the women
move on faster because remember that's
cautious because they've lost a lot of
money so they're not moving on fast but
afterwards they can get a younger person
so the women were got there and they
would say oh we're going to get married
again are we going to get hooked up
we're going to settle down and I'm going
to just go out there and get a young
lady and play the field because they can
so the women might lose that you know
the men lose out more financially but in
the long run of course they got lucky
they can go and get any younger that
they want because when you're a mature
man and you've got money you're
attractive unlike
the women out there that got money
because like if they don't they don't
look all that all the plastic surgery
and stuff that they need to keep up
their looks but maybe just work out and
they'll still look good
can I say something
um Tom Brady so if you've specified it's
a high profile breakup then I'm guessing
we're talking about money here most of
the time I talk about popularity yeah
um can I ask when they actually got
divorced do you know when
um officially October 2022
okay okay right because I was gonna say
because as an athlete Tom Brady's
Spotlight the reason why hidden
Spotlight is always going to constantly
change like when he when he said he was
going to retire the spotlight was on
just retiring ain't nobody mentioned
about him breaking up
but
I don't it was all over the like my
YouTube feed yeah like it was it was
just on um right Megan Kelly just did a
special on it yeah right so I think my
main point so I'm trying to say here is
that the spotlight as an athlete but Tom
Brady is going to change constantly so
people are gonna eventually forget that
he's been divorced if he moves on with
another person so I think for the female
it's more so like she's the one that
broke up if Tom Brady is such a big deal
and I think the hate that's gonna come
for the women is more than it is for the
men just considering the fact that he's
such a high profile athlete would you
say in society men are valued more for
what they build where women are more
valued for the relationships they can
keep 100 100 because Tom Brady can now
design crazy and invest in this many
stuff invest like a billion dollar
company maybe that's what's gonna be
that's what he's going to be in the
spotlight for or it's like Elon Musk I
mean how many baby mothers does he have
but yeah Noah each to their own isn't it
but no one really talks about it right
but if the roles were reversed and it
was a woman and she had the same company
but she had like three I don't know how
many he has but like three four baby
fathers people would still look at her
funny no matter how successful she is
it's gonna be long for her and that's
just how it is unfortunately but
have any of you ever looked at an ex's
Instagram or Facebook to see how they're
doing after a breakup yeah all the time
has anyone ever done that anyone
two two okay so the majority what do you
what do you I shouldn't put my hand up
really because nobody I've been out of
it's on Facebook
I promise
yeah I haven't do you guys get mad if
the girl you feel like is prettier than
you or better looking not just happy
you're you're happy for that yeah
it depends on how soon after yeah break
up yeah so how how soon would would piss
you off versus how soon would make you
happy for them
after she's moved on yeah
[Laughter]
I'm better looking than me
than me does it depend on the X too like
how much you liked the X whether you're
happy for them or mad no no just happy
to move on so I I kind of look at life
as lessons so for me not to be with
someone I mean it's taking me a while to
get here to be fair but it's my stance
now it wasn't previously possibly maybe
before but
I think everyone
there's a reason behind everything and a
why and I think
if we're not meant to be together then
we're not meant to be together
be happy
good luck to the next person
that's just kind of mad I mean I don't
wish you the best
it's taking me a long while to get here
but yeah I just think yeah completely
understand that as well I think if it's
a bad breakup you think you've seen with
somebody else you think yeah she's I'm
glad she's got you I ain't got you yeah
it works both ways but then if it was a
good breakup you know you just spit you
just think to yourself
I've got you there you deserve her
because she ain't gonna be as good as me
but well done
because women are [__]
you're not going to say you're going to
be happy for someone who's part of them
come on but it's a bad breakup better
than a good one
I don't know is it bad what do you mean
it's about like if I if I know was to
break up with someone there's either two
ways I can break up one we have like the
most craziest fight and I say [__] you
and I leave or it could be right we're
gonna sit down and talk we're gonna
figure this out why it didn't work out
by the end of the day I just don't want
to be with you and it's both on both
parties it's the same what's going to
help me like in which circumstance am I
going to be like yeah you know what if
you moved on to another girl I'll be
like yeah good for you do you get it
because either way if if we end up in a
fight and you left I'll be like good for
you you know which would you prefer the
bad breakup or the
sit down and talk like I that's what I'd
prefer anyways well sometimes if it's a
bad breakup it's just like it makes you
get over it faster you think so that's
why I'd prefer bad ones because it's
just like done and out of the way I mean
it's like you don't because you don't
want to deal with the drama of it but at
the same time then you're just over it
you've got things to say oh and that was
a bad breakup what Intel is a bad
breakup it sounds all crazy and I know
what everybody's what's your worst
breakup ever been like
um because it sounds like you said they
do something crazy
just broke into my flat after I ended it
too much I think two months after I
ended it he broke into my flat and hid
in my wardrobe oh my god wow
okay okay
she spoke you're looking over there
so okay
who broke up with you I so it was quite
bad I ended it with him but he had
nowhere to go and I said oh I will
support you you live to get was he a bum
was he living with you yeah I was paying
the rent okay okay
um
was it was he hot
how tall was he damn she had a bit too
long it's just you don't say that to her
you say was he good in bed
I was better in bed no one day broke in
okay okay so you break up with him then
what happens
um so I supported him
through the breakup obviously so he
could get his own place because I knew
if I kicked him out he'd turn back up on
my doorstep
don't want that so he moved out
everything was fine I was even praying
to God like please just let this go
nicely he left
about two a month later I'm hearing my
name outside my house I'm thinking what
the hell calling my family everyone's
saying are you sure you're not having a
mental breakdown
they actually believed I was losing my
my mind
um and then on my birthday which was
like a month after that
it broke into my house he was hiding in
my wardrobe and um
yeah it just went like he he didn't come
out but I could smell him in my house
how long was he there I don't know no
seriously because he was outside and I
ran up the night I took my heels off and
run up four flights of stairs and then
I've gone in shut the door behind me and
everyone's trying to get in and I was
just like when I find you
it's over
um I could just smell him in my flat and
I couldn't find him and then I left and
he broke out afterwards
I've heard of a woman breaking into a
man's but it's the first time I've heard
of a man breaking Auntie what are you
doing if someone stands at your house
like that and comes inside yeah now
you're inside your mind
that's the law
I don't know isn't it my property your
inside I never invited you you know I'm
not leaving you have to get past me
are we fighting them
I'm gonna fight and I'm defending myself
because I'm at the door there's a
difference
legally that's what I mean I know what
I'm saying I know what I'm saying
what else who else anyone yeah crazy
break up worst breakup is it worse
breakup or is it worth the person if the
person is bad yeah the worst breakup I
want to hear yeah
I want to hear that I'll say oh they're
nice breakups if they ever nice breakups
has anyone had a nice breakup I've had a
nice breakup love you yeah most of them
have been nice yes there is there is
such thing as nice breakup guys
tell me about the one that wasn't nice
what happened
uh do I really want to go into that
um I'll just move over it yeah so
way back in my past I'm not gonna go to
my recent way back in my past
um I had someone that was a bit
obsessive actually
he left he finished the relationship and
then
he thought he could go away for the
weekend mess around a bit and come back
and I'd had enough and I said No and
then
um
he was fined him in the streets on his
hands and knees crying begging you know
yeah it's a bit messy
and he would try and break in but he
didn't ever succeed he was trying to
break it yeah he put a ladder up to the
window and also there was a lot there
was a lot
yeah he didn't he didn't get in but it
was weird
yeah
so he put a ladder onto your door and
tried to or um to the second yeah and
then tried to get
yeah did you call the cops
did I collect do you know it was a long
time no I don't think I did I think I
just
got out of the way of the wind he
couldn't get in so what was he gonna do
it's just stupid it was just such a
stupid thing to do okay you go off a
ladder go back down again see ya yeah
all right have fun wow that's I can't
believe there's two people in here yeah
he didn't succeed though and he didn't
hide in a wardrobe
I mean he did do some weird things over
the year but I'm not gonna go into stuff
okay
um is dating a younger more attractive
man than your ex considered a win why or
why not
doesn't it depend on how he treats you
and what person he is um how he carries
himself whether he's holding doors open
for you whether all those nice things
that you like from a man to be treated
like a woman
um is he doing those things does age
really matter
can I just say if I was to date a
younger guy then I am like was dating or
I'm dating whatever the situation may be
I'd probably catch a case
it's crazy
you've got no leeway I've got some
leeway the question's based on the um
is she
I mean I don't know if I'd want to date
him that's that much younger because it
takes a minute it takes men a while they
have to get some things out of their
system before they settle down and
yeah they mature a lot slower I don't
know if I'd want to do that a little bit
and you've got to look at his are you
actually looking to have a are you
footage younger person you're actually
looking to have a relationship I don't I
don't date without having a relationship
I don't get involved with anyone unless
I see a relationship potential I don't
do that sorry one thing that I would
point out is women typically don't want
younger men and attractivists and what
secondary
um I think for men
if they had a you know a younger more
attractive
um new person than their ex then it
would be a win for them because that is
kind of their dating metric that's what
they look for whereas with women I would
typically look for someone that's older
like my partner's a little older than me
um
and attraction you know a lot of times
women can replace that with for example
you know status or money whereas with
men if you're not attractive they won't
even give you the time of the day so the
question was kind of asked in Reverse it
wouldn't be you know a win for women but
definitely for men I think I think that
it'd be a win for women if I mean the
younger person as a younger person if
the younger person was a
more mature
because sometimes you get a younger man
he's more mature than the other man
you've left is it rare it's rare though
isn't it
I'm a River City yeah but it's the man
rare I know you're a rarity but no
sometimes no there's a lot of good young
men out there no but then if you're
actively going out seeking a younger guy
saying oh yeah this is going to make my
husband thought [__] like I'm gonna go
that he's gonna be like oh he's probably
more sexually active probably more
good-looking probably has better things
coming for him I think that's kind of
that's kind of like he tapped like high
key in fact like if you're thinking
about getting with someone to degrade
someone that you've been with before it
kind of just shows your character and I
don't think that's how we should be
approaching it especially right now and
as women I don't think that's how we
should approach it before we get label
the stuff we don't want to so I agree I
think that's good for the different
reason that's slag Behavior
if it's if it's like a 40 year old woman
and a 25 year old man what could what
future could there be no matter how nice
of a young man he is she'll get good sex
for about 10 years before he leaves her
I'll I'll be up for that
then we went to the next one but no I
mean okay
so would you say that's a win then for
her oh it's a win for her
good honor
I'm gonna talk about equality in it and
that the younger man oh good on him he's
out there if I know the woman has got a
bit of dush why not
I think some men like older women
and I don't know whether it's mummy
issues but I feel like they like to be
mothered and I think older women
tend to wrap them up and look after them
yeah no no I just think that older women
knows how to look after a man rather
than the young people nowadays so what
you might see as mother it might be just
a traditional woman looking after a man
and that's what it is because if you get
an older woman there and she decides to
go and give a man dinner on a go and
cook dinner and put it on the tree you'd
be like
see what I mean and you might think oh
she's mothering him but that's what
women do well and younger guys like the
guys that I know that will go for older
women is typically because they want
casual sex and they just think it's
easier to get it from them yeah that's
what I said good sex with 10 years
[Laughter]
and if it lasts longer that's a bonus
would you guys ever date someone for a
long period of time knowing there's no
long-term future
[Music]
basically
no no absolutely not waste of time
you're wasting your youth yeah
don't do it don't you think you may want
to pass in past like someone who's right
for you maybe you may miss them whilst
wasting if you miss someone sounds like
a bus in it catch them again what I said
if you miss no she was saying that I'd
rather next one comes along yeah because
I'm sorry but if you're with someone
then you're just think you know what I
mean just thinking realistically you've
don't have anyone and it's time for us
you buy and then I'll use that right
there all your roses and your lips and
whatever or you find a young man and you
just think you know what I've got you
for five years well I've got a man for
five years and you just enjoy yourself
you're not looking for nothing else you
might be a busy business woman that
don't want a relationship
and you might have come to an agreement
with someone you know what we're just
gonna
see each other but
we've got five ten years to waste I
personally think that only worked for a
short period of time you can only be so
uncertain for a short period of time and
that initially happens at the beginning
maybe like give it three four months
you'll probably start liking them and
being like yeah I want to get into a
relationship but then they're going to
use the fact that you went into the
relationship without no intention of
getting together in the future to
basically go yeah no I'm not really
getting into one that's one of my
mistakes that women make right so I
think it only works for a short period
of time it can only be uncertain for a
very short period of time the sooner or
later you will end up liking the person
believe it or not how soon will you guys
have that conversation of where
something is going
foreign
is that something you guys do on the
first date third date a month in depends
who they are
does it not depend on before you even
get to that point knowing where you're
actually at in terms of wanting a
relationship or not
well I'm saying if you want to be in
something long term yeah and you're
gonna you meet a guy and go on a date
with him how long till you ask him where
it's going
um for me personally it would be before
we become intimate or like I shared that
kind of energy
you just said before you come intimate
so how many dates you're going to go on
before you come intimate I'm just
thinking about the guy could be taking
you out like four or five times and then
you're gonna tell her and I said no you
know I'll be vexed if I was a man I'm
taking you out on five dates and you're
going to talk about getting that for it
I'm gonna be vexed let's be honest I'm
gonna be Vex Damon to you really you're
already dating
think about it from a man's point of
view you like this girl and you're
talking you're going to take her out on
these dates and then after the fifth
date she's gonna be like you know what
um I can't really see a future I'll be
like give my money back you know I mean
I'm wasting my money on you give my
money back I think it should be done
like from day one by the time you
started talking like yeah what's your
name and I'm date with intention you but
like me or you don't like me move on but
to go on dates and then turn around and
say
that I thought you should get keep all
the receipts and that's his money back
but at least 50 but for someone to say
that you really must not have liked the
dates that day you're probably just
focusing on trying to get a different
type of intimacy with a person no the
question was how long would it be before
like if you're gonna get serious with
someone so to go on date she's asking
when that I remember I said to someone
like when you meet someone they want to
take you out say you know what are your
intentions towards me I think I'm dating
with the attention before you even go
out on a date for the time you're going
out on a date you're the you're giving
them false hope you're giving the man
thought so from the time you said yes
I'm gonna go on a date you're thinking
yeah I'm in there and then the next day
yeah I'm in there I'm getting closer I'm
clocking goes now you're not my type
after four or five days
I actually do you think that's what I
was trying to say before it's I think
it's before knowing before you get to
that point
what you want going into whether you're
going to have a date or going into a
relationship I think women know you can
just look at a man and see you know even
before Uganda that you know so when you
go on a date you already know you can
tell by the first date that you don't
like him I mean I kind of maybe
and I think we do feel that and we do
know prior to going forth with anything
else so I do think those that say I just
want to see and wait and see how it goes
on I think deep down we we truly know
before we even go to that point instead
of saying no I'm gonna go on dates with
him because something better might come
along
but sometimes you can know someone's not
right but you're highly attracted to
them so you keep going back
you know some people well there's a lot
of people that sleep around they know
yeah
like a friend of benefit I feel like if
you get into a situationship where
you're basically your friends of
benefits you've kind of already
established what is going on in the
relationship right
but
I feel like if you're
before you even go on a date personally
I'd speak to the person first probably
like give it like a week give it like a
week or two you'd know if you even want
to go on the date that's the thing but
for you to go on five dates and be like
yeah I'm not I'm not I'm being honest
yeah I can then I'll be like I can see
that if I'm being honest a man has to
make my fanny flower if you're not
making my money
I feel like there's nowhere to go like
that has to be that sexual chemistry as
well as that energy and that connection
I think it has to be there I think it is
important yeah but don't forget like
your fanny can flutter at the beginning
you're funny
no I'm saying don't follow you funny but
I have to have that funny flutter with
somebody that I'm gonna be looking I
think that's important part of if I hit
that's got to be in my shopping basket
but being able to that physical
attraction that sexual attraction with a
man as well as being able to have that
intellectual conversation and
have that fun Factor as well I think
there's a lot of so what's not in the
shopping bag what are you willing to
give up
because because if he's a good looking
guy that makes your like Fanny flutter a
lot of women are going to want him so
can I say what I want in my basket and
then everything else can't be in my
basket okay go ahead go ahead
um I think honesty is important I think
communication is key
um
I think I'm at a point in my life now
where I need consistency
um to feel safe and secure
and obviously that physical attraction
have fun what I don't want is somebody
dictating to me telling me what I can
and can't do
um abusive whichever way shape or form
that may look
um
so yeah I think that's a shopping surely
Dave and a basket
yeah so I think you know that's that's
me
what about you guys
what would you guys want to go
I have everything I want now
[Music]
employers don't have it no
X after me he leaves me he does
everything I need thankfully is he more
than five years older than you
uh yeah well he's five years older than
me see that was a good question
[Laughter]
what would I want
um you know I used to be big on saying I
want communication anybody that asked me
what I wanted I'd always be like I'm the
best Communicator in the world I need
someone to communicate just as well as
me but you realize that communication
comes in different forms and it's always
not going to be compatible with you so
even when someone is you'd think they
wouldn't you're asking a man to be a
woman
asking telling you to tell me what you
want it's not asking me to be a woman
I'm just telling you so that you don't
get upset if I don't do the stuff you
want me to do I haven't even told you to
shut up and be quiet
nobody and I hope no one
okay yeah you're lucky
yeah I am well a lot of the time I'm not
gonna stand someone
put a lot of time if men tell us what
they really want we leave because it's
usually um have sex with multiple people
and you stay America so when we get told
that that's their form of honest
communication and we're just like all
right I'm going that's probably why
they're not honest with us
she's got a shopping truly I want to
find out what everybody else wants okay
so good communicator what else
someone that I find
attractive okay is there is there a
height requirement for that you're not
that tall I don't think well I know I'm
five free
um no I don't have a height requirement
you can be as tall as you like five foot
five foot I don't think I'd go for some
other shows
yeah just not sure what they're me sorry
yes no uh hat requirement but just
someone that's not sure than me okay
just because I feel like I'd be more
attracted to someone that was taller
than me than sure same height is good
same height can be yeah it can be all
right we can make it for like five five
at least yeah yeah okay okay go ahead so
tall good Com or five five and up and
good communicator yeah someone does I
said it's so funny someone that I'd
prefer if I was to look for anybody and
I've from the first time I even stepped
my foot into this dating World
um someone that's been in a previous
relationship
but however I don't mean it in a way
where like you're still talking to them
but I mean in a way where like
um you know what is required in a
relationship you know how to go about
someone a significant other and how to
talk to them how to look after them and
I think yeah so I think that's kind of
important to me no no I don't break car
but I would prefer that okay so five
five and taller has been in a
relationship good communicator or
anything else
maybe something I'm not allowed to say
on camera
but yeah that's all I got for at the top
of my head though okay what about you so
I would say I'd like someone to be
honest
and if even if that is brutally honest I
prefer that
um
someone that is considerate
uh someone that I'm attracted to first
of all
that's my number one and then the rest
kind of follows I'm a bit more like
um
I don't mind relaxing some of my wants
if the person is a decent person if he's
got drive if he likes to enjoy life if
he sees
um fun in being alive appreciates being
alive that's
it things can change I'm not so black on
white on things like I've I have dated
okay I was young but I've dated someone
that was shorter than me before
um
actually I only have I've only had two
relationships and both weren't tall so
it's not like I'm looking to break up
with them or did they break up with you
they both broke up with me
um
so what else anything else but obviously
like I said earlier
um
they come back
when they realize the grass isn't
Greener
um but yeah we should take them back if
someone if they came back well I did
with one particular one no not anymore
though that option's not even there
anyway but not anymore
can I ask why they broke up with you
is it you or is it them
I would say it could be
so the first person wanted like I said
earlier I wanted to have fun went off
for he could come back
and I didn't let him come back and that
really upset him
um
second person he did keep coming back to
be honest it's a long story we were
dating since like I was 14.
um 14 to 18 broke up dated the other guy
and then got back with him after and we
were dating for
about 12 years with maybe a year Gap in
between that wow you're with him for 12
years yeah with lucky well 13 years with
a year ago in between yeah wow why don't
y'all get married that was the idea yeah
that was the idea yeah most marriages
yeah it was the idea we we lived as you
know as you would
but you know things change people change
and I think sometimes
um when someone's in an environment
where they're with a lot of younger
people they can change what they want so
initially when we first dated
he would he still would hold all the
doors and everything he's very
gentlemanly
um and he's a very nice person
but he
he would not like it if I attempted to
pay for something he had to pay for
things like he learned to drive because
he didn't like me driving him around he
was saying that sounds amazing he was
like that's I don't feel manly yeah yeah
but at the end when we broke up one of
the reasons he gave is because I don't
pay take him out on dates and pay for
things but he's in an environment where
he hangs around with younger people and
I think he
and may have got a bit messed up along
the ways he had it right in the
beginning you know um he was very
traditional and I liked that about him
he was a good person he treated his ma
that's another thing they have to treat
their mum well
um and I think that that speaks volumes
um yeah but times change people grow out
of each other so he because this just
doesn't make sense so he hung around
younger people and then he was mad you
didn't so he's he's a musician okay
um and I think when other people say oh
my girlfriend bought me this my
girlfriend done this and took me this
place and then it made him think ah why
isn't she doing that but he would have
been angry if I'd done that originally
um do you think there was other ways
maybe you could have done something that
wasn't money that he would have
appreciated oh yeah I did yeah I did he
just didn't take that into account
no
maybe not obviously not yeah that sounds
like he was doing stuff not more so to
have the authority not in a bad way but
to have that Authority being like yeah I
can look after you but kind of just
dismiss the fact that he wanted to be
look after too so maybe that's what he
came back and went cool like you don't
look after me but like for him his only
like his only intention was to look
after you well I don't think I don't
know me based on what I'm hearing that's
what it sounds like but yeah basically
I'm here and he got easily influenced by
his peers and that's what it was he
spent more time with his younger peers
listening to them and sometimes becoming
hard peer pressure can come at any age
yeah I think especially as you were to
give us so young and he was so it seems
like he was
mature when he was young and then he
spent most of his youth being mature and
then when he had the chance to be young
again and be a teenager because he's
lost all his teenage years he just went
for it because he was surrounded by that
I think if he wasn't a musician it would
have been different but being the
musician
that's hard yeah I made him be a
musician as well all right I was like do
it follow you yeah do it it's fine I can
you know take care of things for a
little while that's such a long
relationship it just sounds like such a
it's seemingly smaller thing that and
such a long run oh no there was many
there was many things
um there was many things that he'd done
at the end that were not good but I
don't really want he's a good person
I've got nothing bad to say about him
but he act he behaved badly for a little
while for like six months of our
relationship you behave very badly and
then he's now back to being normal and
everything you know fine I but he yeah
he was a different person I've got
fingers crossed for you yeah no no no no
no I'm rooting for it no hell no you
won't mature yeah no no how old is he
now
he's 40 when he so it was when he was
turning is he with anyone I don't know
he would I don't think he would ever
tell me that's the thing I think he
would you didn't creep no you didn't
check his page
I haven't recently obviously when we
first broke up I looked would it make
you feel we're still on we're still
friends on everything we haven't done
that will it make you feel a type of way
if you told you he was talking to
someone else right now no not so I'm
completely healed like literally
when he moved out I came to terms of it
pretty quick and I am one of those
people that take things as a lesson and
I move on from it so I'm like I could
see so he's done some really bad things
at the end but he's a good person and I
can see the part I played in that so I
can see how my behavior made him behave
that way
um
so I think you know sometimes it can be
easy to
stop doing the things that you do for
each other
and and not keeping things alive you
know
um and I'm not saying in the bedroom I'm
saying in general day to day
um
yeah so I just think that good people
bad situation things went upside down
and that's that's fine and actually I
think I had my best year of my life
since since we split up funny enough not
because he's a bad person it's just
because
I can be me I can do what I want to do I
don't have to consider a partner's
feelings for a little while
um I'm not the type of person to just
move from person to person
um yeah so I'm just good being me for a
little while
I'm still kind of rooting for it no no
no no don't don't no okay whatever
um what about you two what do you guys
look for in a guy
yeah go ahead I've already answered I
said how everything I want yeah she says
I'm sorry I'm sorry it's okay
I want the truth
because I seem to find myself
in the position where I'm always seem to
be the side bit side [__]
um all the time
and I think that's just what annoys me
like
but do you know he's in a relationship
when you meet him no otherwise I
wouldn't go there oh okay so it's
different yeah I just get put in a
position where I find out like months in
one case two years
um that they've been in a relationship
so I just want the truth because it
doesn't hurt me like you could turn
around and say oh this is not serious
and I'd be like it is where it is I want
to have my fun but if why do you think
they put you in that box
I think because I don't necessarily come
I don't come across like I want to have
something serious okay so as much as I
do I'm like in between because I've had
bad experiences before which has made me
feel like I don't want not to live with
me I don't want this I don't want that
but then it comes to I do feel lonely
and I would want that intimacy and that
love from the right person do you think
that that's in a way making the mistakes
of the man of the future pay for the
mistakes of your past
it's kind of like when it's kind of like
when a guy is is always going through
your phone because some girl cheated on
him
in a way
see I always say this rule I won't go
through your phone don't go through my
phone that's going to hurt you don't you
think that before you move on to one
relationship like get rid of the baggage
heal from one before you go don't take
one relationship into the other
can I say I've I've clocked that we've
all been saying honesty but I feel like
personally if you yearn for but like
honesty in a relationship is kind of
like it kind of sucks because like if
you're going to relationship being like
I just want honesty I need you to be
honest with me I need you to be honest
with me it's kind of like do you need to
beg for that but also at the end of the
day I don't know about you guys but
personally for someone that's been
honest with me I have felt hurt before
and it's kind of like also that honestly
doesn't I feel like there's certain
things that you don't have to say
there's certain things that you don't
have to say but if you say it's going to
cause some type of some type of you know
and also can I say guys that are always
honest they normally always honest about
the past relationships and I feel like
if you if you if you've established that
you guys are going to be a hundred
percent about everything you've done
you're gonna feel some type of way
regardless of whether that involved you
or not so they've been doing stuff
before they even knew you but you'd feed
the tap away because they're with you
right now so it's kind of like certain
stuff you don't have to say and it's not
me being secretive if there's certain
stuff that we can talk about we can talk
about that's going to progress our
relationship but if that's about oh like
yeah I used to do like this with her and
like yeah like this and that I think
it's kind of like I think you're right I
don't think women want honesty but yeah
because then they wouldn't keep dating
Liars yeah yeah and be like yeah I want
you to be 100 honest with me but I feel
honest to be honest cheaters I would
rather just cry and be mad and then just
get over it my first reaction always say
tell me the honest truth let the first
reaction go over the head because that's
it soaking in yeah that's the honesty
progress your relationship is it
positive to your relationship though yes
because they know that there's no point
in lying to me I'm not the one you want
to lie to and why'd you say honesty when
I asked when you I asked you what you
were looking for because to me that
implies that maybe you haven't always
gotten that no I haven't
um the past relationships
well because you're a pretty girl you
have a million options there's many men
that will be honest with you but it's
like we pick the Liars no they I don't
know I just feel like they as you said
make my funny fluff so okay it's like
the Liars the lies make you want them
but then you're attracted to the light
yeah
so then what incentive do men have to be
honest with us if the Liars get laid I
just prefer like if you just turn around
and said yeah you're seeing talking to
like two free other girls and I'm just
an optional yeah if they told you that
then they then you wouldn't sleep with
them that kind of links back to what I
said earlier
um a lot of time and this has been
mentioned on fresh and fit another
podcast and when one honestly honesty
but
as the saying goes they can't really
handle the truth because when you are
honest
they immediately leave which you know I
understand but what incentive is there
for men to be honest because they'll
lose the resources they put into you you
know whether it's taking on dates life
advice everything because men help us
with a lot of things when we're with
them
um but then you just leave because
they're with other people which is most
likely the thing that they're not being
honest about and so as you said what
incentive do they have to be honest when
they could lose the whole thing they've
put work into like you must be crazy to
not tell me something that you know I'm
gonna be like yeah I'm Gonna Leave You
for it's kind of like what people are
selfish I mean do you do you go into
relationships telling when your body
count
well it depends anyone ever asked I've
never been asked because never I don't
know because I feel like any guy that
you talk to these day will ask you your
body count really not really not anymore
maybe like two years maybe young people
anymore
it's a young person it's like the
youngest the younger the guys yeah maybe
it's because yeah but I'm just saying if
we're going to be a hundred percent
honest no no because I feel like
especially right like a lot of girls are
with guys where they know if they said
their body count it would end their
relationship so so like there's there's
in a way we're not always honest with
them either because I was gonna say like
if you're going into relationship
nowadays especially like my friends
everybody that I'm surrounded by right
now as a 19 year old they will 100 ask
your body count 100 it's one of the
first thing that comes up what's your
name what school do you go what's your
favorite color what's your body count
it's definitely the age maybe it's the
age thing but in this like in this day
and age right now that I'm in right now
they will ask you with no shame because
when you answer that's the question will
you answer 100 I'll be straight up baby
I'll say this many or this name I've
never had anybody ask me that older men
just don't see the point in asking yeah
they just feel like you're gonna lie
anyway you're right but the last time I
ever got asked that question I think I
was 16 years old that's a good nine
years ago really because
I lied I did get answers all the time
right now and I did give my honest
answer I think with men as well
um obviously you know you can't look at
a woman and be like oh yeah her body
can't exists but you can get an inkling
of whether it's higher or lower and
sometimes that is enough to suffice them
as to whether they get in a relationship
or just have sex you or whatever it may
be I think how you portray yourself is
sometimes enough for them to decide
would it put you off of this if their
body can was like higher than yours
if my partner man's body knows how the
moan no of course not you know I think
men value in experience with whereas
women value experience so my partner
body characters of course higher than
mine and if it wasn't I'd be like where
the hell am I with you if no one else
wants you but did the young lady on the
inside
I don't think that I don't agree with
that but I just expect men you don't
agree with what that um you think it's
because the experience I I don't think
you don't think women value experience
no no I do think they value experience
but I don't think I'd be saying oh your
body count is less than mine so I don't
like that because other women don't like
you okay I mean I don't know that's a
conscious thing but I mean yeah I don't
I don't sit there and think of myself
well these women didn't you've got a
lower body count therefore these women
didn't like you so why am I it's just
you know a silent tick in your head
where it's you know it's like Evolution
it's like when a guy's very I mean one
of guys will tell me getting verified is
the first way to get women yeah because
it's a sign of pre-selection
it's so superficial there isn't it I
mean we can't really change it yeah it's
like it's like telling the world not to
be the world and all in all of history
like women have gone for men that other
women have selected so it's like you can
say it's superficial but that's that's
always what happens yeah like look at um
you know Genghis Khan all the world's
conquerors if women didn't like men that
weren't if women did not like men that
were experienced why do these men that
should have harems of women women just
naturally gravitate 17 women reproduced
for one man every one man eight thousand
years ago
has this saying crazy girls can get who
they want and guys get what they want no
girls get what they want guys get like
if a guy can only get a girl with the
girl wants them he can't just go out and
get the girl girls
can get who they can can I see um sorry
guys sorry
um I feel like just we were talking
about there's like a couple seconds ago
but like I feel like women always say
they want to experience someone who's
experienced
but we'll cry if they find out who
they've been in those experiences with
and how many body count there is can I
just say it because I could say and be
like I want someone who's so experienced
that's going to do this that's going to
do that and make me feel this type of
way but then as soon as okay cool that
happens and they're like okay cool
what's your body count who have you been
in for the past they're gonna start
crying and it's kind of like
choose choose whether you want him to be
experienced and and like is that common
to start asking I just want to hear we
didn't ask her the question about what
she wants in a man oh yeah what do you
look for what do I look for Animals yes
um I feel like even though I'm quite
small
I'd say like five eight um sorry I'm
like five three I've got two little
people yeah
normally I feel short next to Pearl I
feel tall today
um I like command that's family very big
on like family
um big family
I like chivalry
I don't really have like a type like
physically so he's got to be five eight
and he likes his family and chivalry
well he's nice yeah he's got a good
family and teacher what about money
any minimum what if he's unemployed
are you paying the bills till till he
figures it depends on how much passion
he has and what he's doing that's not
paying the bills
it's like really a big thing usually
unemployed people don't have passion
typically
I'll tell you all right welcome to
England
so are we all going to say like money is
a big thing in relationship going into a
relationship right now like yeah money
is a big thing
I've heard everybody mention everything
and for me
all I want is a man that's working
that's going to treat me the same way he
like to be treated and he's got to be
good in bed I ain't gonna have no money
I don't care what you look like I don't
care how tall you are if you're not good
in but it ain't happening I don't care
how much money you got either if you
know and everybody's talking talking
about this funny flutter I mean that
funny fluttering and nobody said about
sex what but so you're funny conflict
and the man's gonna tell me you ain't
gonna be good in bed what are you gonna
do then he's got everything else that's
in the shopping trolley except that
because you put that you need to put
that in the shopping Charlie I missed
that off but that is vital absolutely do
you guys rather have a guy that you
weren't physically attracted to that's
good and bad or a guy that you were very
physically attracted to but he was bad
and bad give me them not physical
yeah I don't mind because I feel like if
you're not good in bed I can always do
that kind of bit myself
so you you would take the hot guy
yeah you take the Hawkeye what about you
I think I think I'd have to be attracted
to him to some degree to be able to lay
down so I'd have to teach I think rather
than not have an attractive man no
there's no word this isn't build a man
it's bad and bad today he's gonna be bad
in bed tomorrow
he does not care give her one yeah
60 seconds that's it
I mean I think that's important for me
they would have to be good in bed so
but then I wouldn't be able to lay with
somebody if I didn't find them
attractive that's difficult and pick one
can't pick one you have to
be ugly and good in bed and good looking
and rubbish
oh you didn't tell me you can't get an
ugly man
is that how superficial you are what I
mean
I think um
it's tough I can't answer I said I never
got that because I always if you get an
ugly man nobody's gonna want him you've
got a whole man for yourself
but then he's not making my fanny
flutter so then it's not but they're
doing it for me so I think I would have
to I would have to yeah maybe but then I
have to look at him it's the good
looking to have to look he has to be
attractive to me and how many hours a
day are you looking at each other versus
how many hours a day are you sleeping
with each other
if you're working if you're going out
together you see it you it's yeah how
many days how many hours a day do you
work about eight how many hours a day do
you sleep about eight that's what you've
got to think about so you're only gonna
see him back before and depending on
sexual positions you don't even have to
look at him
I think
I think I'd have to go with with the
good looking guy that's superficial
isn't it but I think I would have to
yeah most women would there yeah I think
okay would anyone take the the app the
not so good looking guy we're good and
bad me all right you too and then you
would take the Hawkeye yeah I've
actually been with someone that's not
good looking but there was good in bed
and then after a while it's like my mind
just started saying to me they're good
looking it's all right
fine it makes up for it in the beds no I
go for the person that's unattractive
but good in bed because you can learn to
love someone's appearance even if they
don't change you can just gradually
learn to love it whereas sex is quite an
intimate part of relationship so even
though it's not as important for women
as it is for men generally
um it's that'll still be a part of your
relationship missing